Hello world it Saroj and healthcare is the most exciting application of AI
technology.
Using Ai.
We can cure all major diseases,
help doctors,
treat more patients,
and even enhance our own cognitive abilities to superhuman levels.
The school of AI just announced its first global hackathon called health hack at
a launch event in Singapore's National Gallery.
So I flew to Singapore to give a keynote on AI in healthcare at the event as
well as attend a panel discussion on the same topic.
In this video you'll get to see exclusive footage of that keynote and the panel
discussion.
I hope you find it educational and inspirational and if you're new,
subscribe to get notified when I release my videos in Jordan.
Okay,
let me introduce you to Siraj.
Revolver is the founder of the school of Ai,
as I said,
an international nonprofit with the mission to offer a world class education in
AI to anyone on earth for free.
So his youtube channel of Ai Education content has over 500,000 subscribers and
he partnered with you Udacity to launch their deep learning foundations
nanodegree program.
Besides being an AI educator,
Serratia is also a bestselling author,
public speaker,
data scientist contributed to open source projects like open AI and wrapper.
So please join us in welcoming Serratia vol.
Thank you everybody.
Thank you.
See how loud this mic is?
Okay,
perfect.
Good.
Very good.
Okay.
I'm very excited to be here in Singapore.
Uh,
yesterday I flew in from Los Angeles.
He was a 17 hour flight.
So I'm here for a reason.
I believe in the people here.
Um,
I think we can do a lot of great things.
This community here in Singapore can do a lot of great things for health care.
And so in this talk I'm going to talk about AI in healthcare specifically.
I'm going to talk about a AI in drug discovery and a few other applications.
I'm going to list three applications,
my thoughts on them,
and then we're going to talk about for each of these applications,
how this would work using technology.
We're going to get into the specifics.
Okay.
So,
um,
before I start,
I want to talk about what,
what I'm most excited about.
What I'm most excited about is the convergence of biology and information.
So if we think about it,
uh,
the bite by gene and the atom,
let's just think about that for a second.
The bite,
the gene and the Adam.
These are three fundamental building blocks,
uh,
for three different subjects.
The bite for digital information,
right?
The bite from the bites comes,
kilobytes,
megabytes,
and then programs and algorithms and everything else.
Data from the gene,
the gene,
you know,
we all have,
we all have DNA genetics.
A lot of it tell,
makes us who we are,
our traits over into how we think.
A lot of that comes from genetics.
And so biology from,
from the,
from DNA,
from genetic spring's life.
And the third is the atom.
So matter writes,
a lot of amazing innovations have come from matter.
And so in the 20th century we saw a lot of incredible innovation segmented in
each of these fields.
So in biology we sell revolutions in healthcare,
in terms of curious for new diseases and ways of dealing with genes such that we
can create new gene therapies,
different things like that.
When it came to the bite.
I mean,
I don't even need to explain all that's happened in computer science in the past
five decades.
And then for the Adam,
uh,
you know,
physics,
geophysics,
I mean earthquake prediction,
there's so much there as well.
So that's what defined progress in the 20th century.
These three fundamental building blocks,
and it's specifically how we humans use those to make innovations.
But I'm here to say that in the 21st century where we are right now,
what's going to define progress is the convergence of these three fundamental
building blocks.
So the one convergence in particular I'm very excited about is the convergence
of the bite and the gene of information and biology.
Because we have,
because of a computer science,
because of data,
because of algorithms,
we have so much biological data that is now available to us.
You know,
I just had a test done and I had blood drawn and it was like phase three vials
and the lady was taken away.
I was like,
hold on,
I want that data.
She didn't even understand what I was talking about.
Like these,
these three fields are segmented there.
They're separate,
but they need to converge because blood,
my blood has so much data.
I want to know about myself and,
and,
and what I'm into,
what,
how I can optimize my life better using what's built into me,
like what types of food I should eat,
what types of activities I should be doing,
what types of climates I'm best suited for.
Things like that.
And Algorithms,
information can help approximate those solutions.
But that's just one example.
We have several coming up.
So that's,
I just wanted to give you a kind of base frame of thought.
As we go into this AI in healthcare space,
we gotta be thinking about the convergence of the bite and the gene in
particular.
And that's what,
that's what AI in healthcare really is.
So first application is drug discovery.
So,
um,
so specifically in the U S it takes about 10 years for a drug to come to market
and it takes tens of millions of the u s dollars.
Um,
and so that is,
I mean,
it's generally long wherever you are in the world because of different
regulations and that just,
that's just how it is.
That's just how it has to be.
It's not like some,
you know,
nefarious plot.
That's just how it is.
Because of the process of having to select the best candidates for,
you know,
some treatment for some disease.
You know,
a lot of,
um,
molecular biologists and,
and people working in cancer therapy,
they have to pick from,
you know,
11 million plus candidates for what could be the ideal cure for whatever disease
or trying to tackle.
And roughly they're doing this by hand.
But AI can look at this information and scale that discovery in a way that we
humans can't write algorithms,
digital digital algorithms,
digital intelligence can look at data in a way that we can't.
And what this can do is it can speed up this process,
this pipeline from basic research to clinical trials,
all three phases to the review process and until it finally becomes a medicine
that can save people's lives.
So,
um,
let's talk about specifically how this would work.
You know,
technically speaking,
right?
Let's,
let's not just talk about buzzwords.
How would this work?
So let's say we have a key,
we have a genetic database for gene therapy.
We would be using a genetic database.
In the case of let's say cancer,
which I think is the most exciting because this is a major unsolved problem.
We would have a list of a data set of possible,
uh,
drugs that could be used to treat,
you know,
whatever cancer you're trying to treat.
And the idea is that how do we find the needle in the haystack in that,
how do we find the one that sticks out from the rest that is going to be perfect
for this specific disease that we are targeting?
So that would be a discriminatory problem.
We are trying to discriminate amongst a bunch of potential drugs to find,
which was the one that could cure the disease.
But what would be more interesting is instead of framing it as a discriminatory
problem,
we could frame it as a generative problem.
What we're trying to generate the cure by using the existing dataset and
applying some sort of distribution to it.
So what I mean by distribution is we take that initial dataset and we think of
that as a bunch of ones and Zeros.
So in machine learning we think of this input as a matrix.
And what a matrix is,
is it just a group of numbers and it's a giant group of numbers can get big,
it can get as big as you want.
And we take this group of numbers and then we apply a series of multiplication
operations to it that that's what AI is.
It's a series of multiplication operations until the initial input,
which is a group of ones and Zeros becomes an output,
which is a different groups of ones and Zeros and from those ones and Zeros,
this translates to a drug,
right?
So think about it,
the bite and the gene DNA blood,
the basic building blocks of life.
This is information.
So we are using information that we create with electronic equipment to find the
information for cures to diseases.
And so if we frame it as a generative problem,
we can generate new types of drugs that would cure potential diseases.
In particular,
a model,
an algorithm that I find to be very promising in this field,
uh,
are they're called generative adversarial networks,
generative adversarial networks.
And the idea behind these networks is that we have two competing models.
One is trying to generate new candidates for a drug in the case of drug
discovery.
The other one is acting as a discriminator.
And it's looking at this,
what it outputs the,
you know,
the,
the group of ones and Zeros.
And it's saying,
is this secure or not?
Is this,
is this valid or not?
And so this,
these two models play a game where one's trying to generate a cure and one is
trying to discriminate whether it's valid or not.
And that's a very high level idea behind these two mathematical models.
By the way,
all of this is math.
All of this has been,
it's just math.
It's matrix math.
That's it.
It's nothing.
It's,
it's,
it's not more than that.
It's just math.
And so people need to understand that when we're talking about,
this is a bit of a tangent,
but it's unnecessary tangent.
If we're talking about AI and apocalyptic AI and all this stuff,
we're talking about the potential for humans to use math,
specifically matrix math to either exploit other humans or to help other humans
empower other humans.
That's,
that's the,
the issue is humans.
It's not matrix math,
it's not AI.
Ai is just matrix math.
Okay,
so that's a tangent back to this.
So,
generative adversarial networks,
um,
they play this game,
generate discriminate,
and I think this is a very useful model to use in the field.
And so in this hackathon,
I'd like to see,
um,
people try this out,
right?
So there's,
this is readily available.
I have several videos on this.
Um,
there,
there's a bunch of free tutorials on the Internet about this.
So if you searched ga and tutorial healthcare and a bunch of great tutorials are
gonna come up.
So that's the first application that I'm very excited for because there's so
many people who have been affected by this.
You know,
high in particular.
I have someone who I care about who has been affected by cancer.
And so it's,
it's both the personal thing and I'm a general thing as well.
So that's a very exciting one.
The second one,
automated diagnosis.
Uh,
so if we think about the process that,
that a doctor uses to diagnose a disease,
they are using their five senses.
They're using their human vision,
biological vision.
They're using their sense of touch,
right?
They're using their sometimes even smell,
um,
different things like that.
And so to try to diagnose what a diseases,
and again,
this is a discriminatory problem,
they have a set that in their head and their biological intelligence,
they have a set of potential diseases that this could be,
and they're trying to discriminate based on the input data,
right?
What,
what diseases could be.
And so if we frame it like this,
the reason I'm repeating this is because we have to frame it as all,
all of it.
This is just information healthcare,
it's all information,
digital,
GE,
genetic information.
It's all information.
And so if we think about that process,
how do we automate this electronically and how do we help help doctors help make
their lives easier?
This is not something that will replace doctors.
It could if we want it to.
But if we frame it as how do we a doctor's ends and make it so that they can
scale the number of people that can help,
then this could be a good thing for doctors.
And this then this could be something that doctors would embrace.
So one example in particular a radiologist's,
right?
So radiologists,
um,
there most of their job,
80% of their job is to look at these images and use their biological vision to
try to decipher whether or not someone has a disease.
Ai has now been proven to be better objectively than radiologists.
Actis what in radiologists could do with this technology is they could scale the
number of people that can be treating at the same time.
Uh,
and a lot of countries across the world,
there's not enough doctors to treat,
you know,
the number of people there are.
So this is just a scaling technology for doctors in that that's one thing that
it does.
So automated diagnosis,
we're using convolutional networks.
Convolutional networks are a type of,
again,
Matrix math combination.
It's just,
it's a particular set of operations between that input data.
You're,
all of these,
all AI is just a different set of operations between four input data.
Sometimes you,
you do three multiplications and then you do a division,
sometimes you do two multiplications and then you do,
you multiply it by a specific type of function,
right?
So it's just,
it's just mixing up these different operations to see what would be the ideal
for whatever our goal is.
And in this case,
our goal would be automated diagnosis.
So the input data in this example here are a series of brain scans for
Alzheimer's.
And so radiologists and um,
you know,
neuroscientists and you know,
different types of brain doctors are looking at this manually with their,
with their biological vision.
But again,
this is information,
this is information we can do this better.
And so automated diagnosis is something that I'm very excited for in particular
and we can use again,
convolutional networks,
which are a type of matrix math operation set that's useful for classifying
images and saying what is in this image?
So if we have a Dataset of um,
all timers,
images with the label,
so you know,
think of it as an excel spreadsheet.
One column is just a bunch of images of,
uh,
of,
of brain scans.
And the other column is just yes or no is does this patient have Alzheimer's or
no?
Right?
So just two columns and that using that Dataset,
we give it to a convolutional network network.
By give it,
I mean convert that into a series of ones and Zeros,
multiply it by whatever model we're choosing to use.
In this case convolutional network,
it's going to give an output.
And the learning process here,
what it's doing well,
it's a learning.
These mathematical models,
they have a set of,
again,
matrices of ones and Zeros that through this optimization strategy,
it's updating itself.
And by updating,
by learning what it's really doing is it's strengthening the connections between
different parts of this input image to know what it means to have Alzheimer's.
And what I mean by saying what it means is what parts of that image contribute
to Alzheimer's,
what w what is the essence of what Alzheimer's is?
And it represents this as a series of ones and Zeros.
It learns this representation.
And so we,
we keep a representation in our head after,
you know,
if,
if we have gone,
if we're a doctrine,
we've gone to metal medical school by looking at many,
many,
many images of this.
And so we can replicate this electronically as well.
So automatic diagnosis is a very exciting application of AI in healthcare and
convolutional networks are just one type of model,
many other types of model.
And this is by far this is not a solved problem at all.
So there's so much all of these,
by the way,
we were literally on the precipice of this new revolution of the intersection of
biology and information.
This is a really exciting time to be in this space right now.
So that brings me to application three,
which is personalized medicine.
I mean,
like I said,
when I got my blood tests done and I was just looking at that,
I was thinking like,
this is data,
all of this is data and I want this data because I want to help optimize my
life.
I want to get into,
I want to not have to go to the hospital.
I want to have this preventative assistant telling me what I should and
shouldn't be doing.
Um,
that has my best interest in mind.
You know,
if maybe,
you know,
I'm about to eat something and it's like,
no,
don't do that.
You know,
you should eat this or something like that.
Right?
So this is,
these are just ideas of how this could work.
But the idea behind personalized medicine is doctors are expensive.
Not everybody has access to a doctor.
So if we can automate the whole diagnostic process and to a personal assistant
that everybody has on their phone and everybody has a phone and everybody will
get a phone as the cost of these machines dropped drastically,
um,
8 million people will come online this year,
which is very exciting.
They're going to have access to personalized medicine.
If we can put this technology again,
this set of matrix operations,
mathematical operations on to a server that they can access via a website,
upload their information,
and then they have their own doctor in their pocket.
So that's super exciting as well.
Our goal as an organization at school of Ai is to help solve the 17 what are
called sustainable development goals,
which we'll talk about at the end.
But this is a big one.
This is one of the sustainable development goals outlined by the United Nations.
So there's one more I want to talk about and that's the most exciting to me.
It's also the most futuristic,
but that is synthetic biology.
So again,
the bite and the gene genomic data is really interesting.
There are so many applications to create new types of not just gene therapies.
When we think about genetics,
we think about generally we think as a,
as the public,
we think about using genetics to try to fix some problem that we have.
But what I think is more exciting is not gene therapy,
but gene enhancement.
What if we could use our genetics to create some new type of drug that could
increase our intelligence by orders of magnitude.
And by intelligence,
I mean our ability to learn children are much better learners for language than
we are as adults.
But we can replicate that as adults.
What if we could be like sponges and learn,
you know,
Mandarin and a week with this,
with this new type of drug.
So super intelligence is something that I would be really interested in.
New Types of gene enhancement,
not just intelligence,
but endurance.
I'm reversing aging.
These are things that aren't sounds very science fiction.
But again,
there's so much possibility when it comes to combining biology and information.
Another one that I find in particular,
very exciting.
You know,
I was just on the plane and I watched five movies because it was such a long
flight.
One of them was Jurassic world.
And I was looking at the idea,
I was thinking in my head,
I was like,
oh,
okay.
In this movie they,
the scientists found this sample DNA and they reconstruct it,
a dinosaur from it.
But the reality is that the half life of DNA is something like 520 years.
But dinosaurs were around 60 million years ago.
So it's all of that DNA is gone now.
And so a lot of leaders in that space have said that,
oh,
you know,
we just can't do that because the DNA is gone.
But what they haven't thought about is using,
are using generative models,
not necessarily use that DNA to,
uh,
add different splicing,
whatever's missing,
but to completely regenerate that DNA from scratch using the DNA that we already
have from genomics data.
So think about it as reverse engineering what their DNA would be from the
existing DNA that we have.
And so yeah,
we could have Jurassic Park be real.
I think it's possible.
So I hope to see a startup like that in some at some point,
but also a synthetic biology is very interesting.
It's,
it's super,
super,
like we haven't even begun to think about the possibilities of say molecular
computing.
I mean that,
that's kind of out there.
But use DNA can store something like 200 terabytes.
I'm just kind of guesstimating here,
but like a lot like a single strand of DNA can store and does store terabytes
and terabytes and terabytes of data.
And if we could use,
if we could somehow modify DNA to both store data and to process data,
we would need these machines,
these phones in our pocket anymore.
They would seem like ancient and they will in the future.
And by the future,
I mean,
I hopefully in the next 20 years or so,
but using DNA as not just data but as a mode of computing and for storage is
wildly exciting because think about deep learning,
right?
So in 2012 that's when the deep learning revolution started abusing these 30
year old models.
Um,
all of a sudden they just became amazing at image classification.
All of these other tasks and the reason for that was because we had better
compute and more data.
Those were the two reasons,
right?
Because we have better compute and more data.
These ancient,
not ancient in terms of computer science,
they're ancient 30 year old models.
All of a sudden it worked really well.
So imagine if we had computing that was orders of orders of orders of magnitude
better than the best GPU and Tpu on the planet,
then we could use these existing models and have,
again,
a whole new revolution.
So something like molecular molecular computing and molecular storage has a lot
of potential for creating an entirely new paradigm of computer science and
opening up an entirely new paradigm of Algorithms and possibilities.
And all of this comes from the,
again,
the intersection of the gene and the bite.
By the way,
if you want to learn more about this,
the gene,
the bite the Adam,
I didn't make this up.
This came from a book I read called literally called the gene by Siddhartha
Mukherjee who who's an oncologist.
So definitely read this book.
It's a great book by the way.
This is going to be super useful to you,
like outside of all this,
what I do when I read his,
I read books,
I read books by listening to them as audio books at three x speed.
And so in the past six weeks I've read 13 books.
Um,
and so what I do is I just kind of like sit there.
I'm listening and I'm not really doing anything.
I'm just sitting there and I'm listening and I'm absorbing the information.
And I've had,
and I've said this on my channel and my youtube channel,
but a lot of people were skeptical,
but even now I'm getting people who are saying surrounds you don't know how much
I'm learning now.
Like I was skeptical that I could do this.
Like three x is way too fast and I'm not a native English speaker and you are so
I can't do this.
Well guess what?
You know a lot of my subscribers primarily from India as well,
are able to do this now.
Not a lot like three.
I got three of them,
like tweet it to me that they could,
which made me very happy.
So,
so you got to,
you got to work up to it.
It's like,
it's like,
you know,
you're lifting weights,
you're not going to be,
I couldn't do three x when I first started,
you know,
I can only do like 1.5 Max.
But if you start at one and then go to 1.5 and do that for like two weeks,
three weeks,
your brain,
your neurons,
your connections,
they're going to,
they're going to update,
they're going to strengthen.
And I see someone shaking their head,
no,
this is real.
This is real.
I'm seeing there's still so much skepticism around the possibility of this,
but it's a real thing.
Try it out.
Don't take my word for it.
Try it out yourself and you'll,
and you'll see.
But this is a great way to taking a lot of information and until we get to the
time where we have devices and maybe Jean enhancements that help us accelerate
how fast we can learn.
This is a great,
um,
midway points,
like listening to things at three x speed video as well.
I do that even my own video.
So these,
these four applications,
there are a part of our mission to help solve these 17 sustainable development
goals outlined by the United Nations.
So the idea is that these are very ambitious goals and the United Nations
outlined by 2030,
which is actually,
you know,
like only 11 years away.
It's,
it's pretty ambitious.
They want to solve all of these no poverty,
zero hunger.
These are like,
these are very ambitious initiatives and,
and we have school of AI believe that with this AI technology,
using the massive data sets that are available to us on the Internet today,
that anybody anymore has access to,
regardless of where you're born or you know,
what your profession is or what your schooling is,
you will,
you are able to make an impact with this technology.
And we believe that with the combined effort of the globe put together people
from across the world,
from different cultures,
different viewpoints,
different perspectives.
If we put this together,
we can come up with these incredible solutions using this technology and we can
accelerate,
um,
the,
the progress towards these goals.
And our goal in particular is to make these happen by 2025 not 20,
30.
And once we do that,
once we're able to solve these goals,
what that means is for the,
for the majority of the world,
as everybody comes online and everybody will be online,
and then within the next decade,
all of humanity,
mostly like 99%,
it's going to be online.
And then we have an entirely new internet culture.
When this happens in everybody's basic needs are,
are met,
then we can get to the stage of creativity and innovation globally and it's just
going to build on itself.
And we're just going to accelerate and accelerate and accelerate.
And it's a very exciting time to be alive in human history right now when we
have the potential for these technologies to solve these incredibly hard
problems and enhance our,
our way of life,
um,
make,
improve our lives,
improve our relationships with people and improve just the way we act in the
world and how we know about all the complexity in the world.
Simplifying it such that we know exactly what to do,
when to do it.
We're more confident.
Uh,
we,
we feel better about ourselves.
Just overall we're,
we're trying to increase the wellbeing,
the health,
the intelligence,
the emotional intelligence of humans using this technology.
And we very much think it's possible.
Thank you.
So now I'd like to introduce you to our panelists.
So first up we have,
I use Chicana.
So are you sure.
Is Cofounder and CEO of [inaudible] Oh,
I AI,
sorry.
Eight.
Oh,
AI.
An AI solutions from an incubator.
She's advised governments and corporations on AI,
smart cities and Fintech.
And she's on the board of Infocom Media Development Authority,
which is the government agency behind Singapore is a smart Nation Vision Asia
has a phd in information systems and innovation from the London School of
Economics as written two books and multiple articles and technology and
innovation and has been named one of Southeast Asia is groundbreaking female
entrepreneurs by Forbes magazine.
Thank you for joining us today.
Are you sure?
Next up we have doctor Victor Tang.
Victor is the chief digital and information officer at the National Gallery
Singapore where we find ourselves today.
He was the founding director of a star is social and cognitive computing
department and the head of biomedical informatics at the Institute for Infocomm
Research.
He's also held senior roles at companies like Pfizer and SAP research.
Victor has a phd in biochemistry from the National University of Singapore and
his work has won numerous awards including the Mit Tiara 35 award and the World
Economic Forum,
young global leader who's welcome Doctor Victor Tom.
Next up joining us is Charles Coosbay.
Huh.
He leads Accenture's artificial intelligence practice in Southeast Asia.
He has over a decade of experience in AI across industries including Fintech,
advertising,
security,
and the military.
In the past six years,
chars lists founded two AI startups,
one focused on predictive maintenance for the oil and gas and the other on fraud
detection and credit scoring for unbanked populations.
So please welcome Charles.
And last but not least,
we have Dr 10 10.
We is the CEO of the National Super Computing Center in Singapore where he
manages Singapore's first pentascale supercomputer is also the founder of the
bioinformatics center at Nus,
the Asia Pacific bioinformatics network,
the first Internet service provider in Singapore.
He,
he founded it and oversaw the creation of the multilingual internet domain name
system.
And wired magazine has called him one of the people who built the Internet.
So please welcome Dr Tamsen Week.
And of course we'd like to invite Eaker and Sarraj again to join us up on stage.
And our first topic that we're going to be talking about today is ethical Ai.
So that might seem a bit vague to people who are new to this question.
So maybe one of you can can make that more concrete.
What are we talking about when we're talking about Ai and ethics?
Is this like Alexa and Siri getting together to rob a bank or something?
Like what,
what is the problem?
It's grabbing Mike.
Maybe I'll,
I'll make a headstart.
Um,
I guess maybe a way of putting the problem is when you look at the way
traditional software programs also we're systems or capabilities are built,
there is a very easy way for us to explain the decisions that are taken by that
solve whether is a deterministic link between the input on the output,
right?
Um,
the moment we perhaps put artificial intelligence into the equation,
um,
such lien gets a bit more blurred and the decisions and the system or making in
the context of think of a classic example that comes to mind is autonomous
driving.
So to autonomous cars are going to be in an unavoidable collision.
Um,
does the system have to make any decisions that affect who survives and who
doesn't survive?
For example,
what are those considerations that are going to be taken into account?
How do those decisions get taken?
What are the parameters?
What are the outcomes?
What,
um,
why do we take the decisions we take?
And how did the system,
uh,
reach the conclusion?
That's perhaps one,
one way of starting the topic.
Does anyone have a differing opinion?
Is,
is that,
is that the problem?
Is the problem of inscrutable AI,
AI models that do things.
We,
uh,
maybe you can't take responses.
That's definitely one of the problems.
I totally agree.
I think that one can kind of divided into three problems.
One is explainability which is even for AI engineers,
sometimes it's hard to understand why it actually came up with it.
Then his interpretation,
which is for the business user or for the domain expert who's partnering with
the Ai Engineers.
And the third is ethics.
So are you with what it's doing?
And in ethics itself,
there is two ways.
One is I think when you,
you don't create algorithms that are deliberative,
deliberately manipulative such as all the deep fake algorithms and the potential
over there that you keep your data processes,
lineage and transparency in order.
Those are some of the recommendations by IMD A's framework for ethical AI.
And um,
and then the third is trying to really,
um,
you know,
establish global ethics.
And then I guess cultural ethics.
I mean,
different countries may have their own,
um,
limitations may put our,
their own limitations while others may not.
So if you look at Gdpr,
I think it's uh,
I personally think it's a really good standard for the rest of the world to
follow because it really puts human rights as data rights,
uh,
or data rights as human rights,
right at the core of how we approach algorithms.
Okay.
So is there room then for research in AI to teach us more about global ethics or
cultural ethics are what we want those things to be as a society?
I guess a bit of a tough question to big,
but I guess a way of looking at it is that the fact that AI exists and it's
something that is totally unavoidable because I guess it puts a spotlight on
those questions and it is going to force that conversation to take place,
right?
Maybe in a more elevated or intense way that it has been happening so far.
I mean,
I think the dumb way to do it is to get either a bunch of lawyers as policy
makers or to get all like engineers together.
Whereas we really need to have a diverse team.
We need more people who are philosophers or artists or people who come from
different domains to get together.
This is literally something that's going to impact society and economy to such
an extent that perhaps it's even rewiring our social contracts with the
government and good corporations.
So it requires a more diversity and the people who address it.
Totally agree with that.
Yeah,
that's a great point.
And now we need more diverse a set of people other than engineers making these
very important decisions that are affecting all of us,
all of us that use,
for example,
social networks.
Facebook is the easiest example to make fun of because of the amount of
industrial scale,
manipulation and exploitation that it,
that it does in the name of its business.
And so Facebook is Facebook's newsfeed,
for example.
It's like my favorites algorithm to trash basically because Facebook's newsfeed
is an example of a runaway AI.
It's making decisions that even its creators don't understand at this point
because of the amount of data that it's using to show you what it thinks is
going to maximize your attention.
So their business model is,
is ads right?
Our ads.
So it's revenue.
The revenue they get mostly are from ads.
And so the longer they keep your eyes on screen,
the more money
they make.
And this is bad because if we look at,
um,
you know,
a lot of studies of children who are using social networks a lot,
uh,
it,
it causes anxiety and depression.
This is a,
this is a,
this is a proven thing.
It's not just a fake thing.
So being on social networks too much is objectively bad for your mental health
because,
because mainly it's optimizing for your attention.
Whereas ideally it would not be optimizing for your attention.
It would be optimizing for your time well spent.
What would benefit you the most?
What is the content that would help you with whatever your objective in life is?
What would be educational,
what would not be violent,
but instead promote cooperation and empathy and things like that.
And we're not there yet because we just built this system and we just built this
billion person plus scalable Ai Algorithm and trained it on,
um,
maximizing attention.
But maybe in the next phase we're going to clean up what I consider to be
digital pollution and instead make it cleaner,
cleaner data,
cleaner information that is going to optimize for your time well spent.
And I would encourage you all to look up literally time well spent because this
is an actual movement I seek at the end of the day it's you proves also some
things that menu of Wisconsin way existing post pre.
I actually if we talk about credit scoring and other type of application,
well if you consider putting the location of an individual into a decision
making system,
it is not fair because it's not because you're living in a poor neighborhood
that you not someone trustworthy.
And yes,
this is a program that is being raised with AI concern,
but does that mean that he was not existing before?
So maybe at the same time as we're working on those frameworks falls the AI.
So I'm seeing even on the,
on the humanity on the w some seem to consider also because at the end it's kind
of replicating a lot of the things even regarding Facebook feeds well feeds,
Facebook feeds is only replicating what TV China's also doing,
trying to optimize the revenue and a certain way because it's easy to eat to
conserve contents.
So that's a thing.
It's a great question to ask.
And his own not only concerning,
uh,
AI,
it's a society issue here.
Yeah,
that's,
that's a good point about,
you know,
these being preexisting issues.
I or there's this now very well publicized phenomenon of judges sentencing more
harshly right before lunch then right after breakfast.
And uh,
so,
you know,
that's the same kind of bias that you can get with,
with humans that you could get with the machines that are trained on bad data or
you know,
uh,
that with,
without those precon without those notions in mind very carefully.
But here again,
we have also to be caught
correlation versus causation because if you can get numbers like that,
we had this conversation with my team earlier this week.
You can have a statistics that tells you that you have more murder when you have
more ice creams being sold.
So we also have to be careful on those kinds of
right because it's the heat and stress.
Um,
so,
uh,
are you sure.
And,
and Sarah as you were talking about that we need more people.
We,
this is more than just a problem for engineers or lawyers and we need more
diversity and this is something that's going to affect everyone.
So,
uh,
maybe Dr Tami,
you can tell us,
what do you think is an institution like,
like the National Gallery where we are here,
what is that the role of such institutions and helping educate the public and,
and uh,
and helping ensure that we see the more positive sides of those results.
Then the more negative ones.
Do you do or do you see that that institutions like the national guy who have a
role in that,
I guess at the application of Ai to improve or optimize our process or we do not
say go into the aspects by I guess a phantom mental problem.
I thought about ethical Ai.
It be customer part,
the culture differences,
for example,
it may be different across our different organizations or even across different
[inaudible] society.
So how do you actually reconcile all these things?
Because when I talk about ethics,
if I take the first two different,
has different meanings to different populations or two different people,
how do we actually know,
get everyone on board to agree on certain size of piece of birth are course of
practice.
Yeah.
And I suppose that that's another one of those problems that exists before AI
and will exist afterwards.
Um,
so maybe we can,
maybe we can transition now to the topic of healthcare and,
and some of the implications of AI for healthcare.
Uh,
so,
uh,
we talked,
so Raj talked about,
um,
the impact of 80 of Ai on,
on a radiology in particular,
but,
and the potential for,
for,
uh,
personal assistants and stuff like that.
What are some of the areas where we're starting to see a impact of AI in
healthcare or in bioinformatics or any of those areas right now?
Well,
that seemed the most of the singer Venus brilliantly covered by a Sarraj area.
So she's referred to what had been said before.
But I think in general we can see that a I is e helping at predicting what's
going to happen next day.
Being a,
being able to detect a slightly before doctor d first science of any kind of
cancer or any kind of health issue being about optimizing this is where he
brings a lot of values,
assisting doctors but also assisting you in trying to predict and small sub the
you're all uh,
uh,
the way you leave in order to optimize.
Yes.
So you get the average person gets super powers,
essentially gets medical,
uh,
medical superpowers.
I don't know if it's super powers,
but it's a statistical,
uh,
knowledge about
okay,
if I do that statistical superpowers.
So
adding onto some of the comments,
that's your I shared earlier on,
um,
on cancer being one of the key applications here.
I have,
you look at the Saudi,
I think a lot of us have experienced this in our families and our relatives.
It's,
it's a very complex journey for the patient.
And a journey that that has a lot of different stages in which when you've gone
through that journey,
you can clearly see a lot of aspects in which artificial intelligence can really
play a role in helping early diagnostic,
for example,
certain types of cancer has proven to be the difference between survival or not
survival,
right?
So having that radiology is being able to detect with the help of that,
perhaps super power of having those super computer eyes that are helping the
take something in its earlier form that is totally a big to the human eye.
That will be the difference between life and death for so many people.
Um,
one of the situations how experienced in this particular case was,
um,
when a patient goes through chemo,
you clearly tell that there's something different in that treatment.
Do anything else,
right?
Secondary Effects,
collateral effects of the medication they're giving you,
they will give you a list.
These are the known things and that could or could not happen to you.
This is the phone number you call when you experienced anything else.
So we can learn from it.
And we think about that,
right,
that that sounds like a space where artificial intelligence can start gathering
all that data and we can continue to learn from that.
And it's,
it's,
it's a disease that puts us all into the unexplored territory perhaps or one
would definitely,
we can see some application.
They're
given a very good overview about the use of AI for a chunk design.
So
design specs in,
we look at using data or weak virus I said needs to trigger new rest points,
but it seems,
for example,
scientists have been using AI AI to identify regions of the five tech Tekken
Chica t cell response.
And so many of these are newer payment,
for example,
hip since multiple sclerosis vaccines answer but food that since my son,
but he's undergoing different stages of our clinical trials,
some in a free spot for HIV interface to treat for no [inaudible].
So these are some of the potential applications tech can be,
I can be used for vaccine design so far track design.
So I just saw actually comment on,
um,
uh,
the importance of the school.
Uh,
organizations like the school of Ai as a lot of education that needs to take
place before the health care community can actually latch onto this extremely
powerful technology.
Of course,
that's with a powerful technology that comes with great responsibility.
And,
and,
and the whole spectrum of,
um,
uh,
ethic ethics,
there has to guide us in the way we apply these incredibly powerful
technologies.
And in particular Ai,
which has the capability of surpassing a human intelligence and also this
possibility that an artificial thing that is divorced from human consciousness
that is able to now predict things far better than anybody the so called super
powers that you described.
And so it's,
it's critically important for us at this juncture of time,
uh,
for us really look at this incredibly powerful technology and,
and put in place a,
an educational process that will help us understand what are the things that we
can apply to and what we shouldn't be doing right?
And these ethical issues that arise,
uh,
touched to the very core of us as human beings.
A human beings are a conscious and we are moral creatures.
And therefore,
if you are envisage an artificial environment where a machine that does not have
consciousness now has super intelligence,
uh,
then that difference now starts to create a lot of,
impossible and very difficult situations,
uh,
that,
from,
from day to day activities like deciding fever,
an autonomous vehicle were to crash,
should it crash this way or that way.
And then you've got to,
you've got to make that value judgment in making a pronouncement of a cancer
patient as to what sort of treatment he has to take all of that,
the end for you,
is it ethical to tell a person that,
I'm sorry,
it's incurable.
It's the end.
You have no hope that robs the person of all hope,
but the intelligence says,
yeah,
it's correct.
It's a fact.
Do you want to say that to a person?
Is it ethical for you to say that to a person?
So it's important now for us to understand as a human beings with morality and
consciousness that we are venturing into a scenario where we are talking about
artificial intelligence,
artificial superintelligence that probably is smarter than all of us at this
stage.
And it keeps learning.
Whereas human beings,
we are all born clean slate and we need education now to bring us to the point
where we are smart enough to be able to have this conversation.
So that brings me right back the way the school of Ai has a very critical task
to play,
particularly in the healthcare community.
I'm 29 years,
19th of February at the school of medicine.
Okay.
So you introduced me as being an internet pioneer.
Well,
I'm a professor in the biochemistry department.
By the end,
the last 30 years I've been trying to introduce bioinformatics and along the
way,
no traction.
So I did sightline projects like the Internet,
like super computing,
like multilingual domain names and so
on.
And I gained significant traction there.
But in my department,
in my school,
it's still a long way to go and let,
that's the medical school,
let alone the entire establishment of the healthcare system.
It takes a long time.
So even as we are really excited and,
and I'm a technology guy,
right,
and really excited about technology,
but it never underestimate how long it takes for us to actually educate people,
changed the mindset to adopt a technologies in an ethical manner.
Oh,
that's really interesting.
Yeah.
Um,
I,
um,
on that,
on that topic of,
of you know,
how,
how it's been taking a long time in the,
in the areas that you're involved with,
is there something specific about healthcare or the healthcare industry that,
uh,
that makes that the case where,
where,
for example,
as the Raj mentioned,
you know,
a lot of these,
um,
these techniques are based on academic papers that have been published for
decades and,
and the research that goes on today,
uh,
especially,
you know,
championed by organizations like open AI is out in the open and researchers out
in the open.
Is there,
does that fit well with healthcare?
It does.
That kind of open open,
does the open source philosophy fit well with healthcare or is there some other
reason why maybe things are it,
it's taking longer as you said to for that adoption to,
to,
to take hold.
A lot of healthcare data is private for good reason because it's very sensitive
data.
And so people working with healthcare have to find a way to get this data
finesse their way to be having access to this data.
But what I think is a great startup idea that it's one of many,
but like if I had the time I would be working on this.
Uh,
but what,
what would be a great startup idea is to offer a service to these hospitals and
other healthcare providers that offers to anonymize their data and sell it this
anonymous data directly peer to peer to trusted entities at they vetted.
So that would be like anonymized data as a service.
Hod Us anonymize data as a service for healthcare.
So if you can prove to these and that that's a great kind of startup to do on
the ground because you can physically go to these offices and you know,
work your magic and try to sell this idea and just build your repertoire and
trust over time.
But if you could do that,
then all this anonymized data would become more publicly assessable to people.
So see,
rod,
you talked about your vials of blood,
you donate it,
right?
You actually gave it away.
And the data that's associated with it and the metadata that's associated with
it,
it's actually help in the,
uh,
in a database somewhere in the hospital and the data belongs to them.
You're going to get the copy.
You might get a download at a,
a CD.
Now they stayed,
they,
they give you a CD of all of your scans.
Right?
But just,
that's just about it until the medical information of a patient now belongs to
me myself.
Um,
it's a long,
hard road because right now the medical profession keeps that information and
for good reason.
Um,
privacy ECS for example,
in Singapore,
we have had a recent spate of a loss of medical information and by the millions
and the whole issue about,
uh,
what surprised my,
my private medical information and how it impacts on me,
myself to my family members,
or more importantly,
perhaps my insureability,
right?
How would the insurance agents now,
uh,
assess the amount of premium I have to pay if they knew that I was suffering
from this or that genetic disease or my propensity towards a particular
cardiovascular event and so forth.
And with super intelligence,
you could almost predict to a son a very high percentage of accuracy.
So does this legal Albie,
uh,
whether I'm going to develop this other disease and war,
my insurance premium exceed the point where I become uninsurable.
Right?
So these ethical issues now and possibly even a lot of the legal issues now
become entangled and in twine inextricably with all these powerful technologies,
uh,
that,
that we are trying to promote here.
Yeah,
I think that's a really good point.
It's one thing to introduce AI to medical students at a hospitals,
but actually it's as important to introduce it to lawyers.
They need to study this as well or business students.
And what my company does is we work with a lot of large enterprises in Asia to
introduced and build AI solutions for them.
And we see a lot of resistance in the beginning because of politics and no Shia,
all of the usual things.
And this idea of privacy that is,
that is not even technically sound sometimes just because they don't even
understand whether something is available or not available or is truly protected
or not.
And I think everybody is just afraid of their own jobs.
They are kind of afraid to take this first step.
So,
um,
making it easier for them with some kind of the repeated pilot or proof of
concept as,
as a lot of companies are trying now and the Singapore government is subsidizing
I think is a good way forward.
And we need to get all small and medium enterprises that are 70% of the backbone
of this country.
We need to get them some basic education.
And then access to the cloud and access to software that they can upload their
data in and began to see some returns on investment.
I think that that's it.
One is the education sector and the other is a business sector really seeing
some return on investment.
The problem is they all expect something they saw in the movies.
I,
there are so many times when I,
when my team we're ride know ride some,
some predictive Algo at them and the data wasn't good,
it was dirty,
Blah Blah Blah and then when I thank God we got like 70% it's amazing and then
they look,
ah,
70% not 99% and it say they're obsessed with is hundred percent 99% number
because they,
they've been going to too many movies are looking at wired magazine and I think
that they,
they need to know it's a process and all of those things are really important to
keep in mind when you're trying to introduce it.
Obviously I'm very interested in seeing how did you say to businesses as well as
to students?
Yeah,
I actually,
I'm really interested in that.
In that obsession with the hundred percent thing because that's something I've
come across as,
well maybe this is a bit of a of a distraction,
but let's see if it,
if it strikes a cord.
So I'm personally interested in self driving cars and whenever I talked to
someone about self driving cars,
they say,
well how can you make the self driving car perfect?
And I'm saying,
well I'm not perfect and I can drive a car.
Like why are we not asking that question about like how can I make sure that
you're perfect that driving a car before I let you drive the car?
Right?
So why is it that our expectations of the software that we build is perfection?
Whereas our expectations of ourselves is like as long as we are,
it's okay.
I don't think he's is very related to that.
The hype curve we see whenever a new technologies introduced,
right?
There's always like this typical curve off.
You know there's a lot of high becomes a buzzword.
It'd be one,
one syllable and expects the world out of it.
Then this is dissolution men.
When you realize that 100% is not going to happen,
but you may get 70 and eventually we get to the point that you know what 82 is
pretty good.
Right?
And I think if you look at all the applications we're using,
I really like what you just said on the introduction and,
and,
and the fear or sort of the apprehension I think is a journey and improperly
power to the journey to the cloud as well as an example.
I probably more an easier one to two to understand.
Um,
a lot of companies in different degrees in every industry are moving to the
cloud and moving to the cloud as a journey in which they,
as they understand the risks and the advantages,
they feel more and more comfortable moving,
more complex,
more critical workloads to the cloud.
And I think artificial intelligence is just a journey that we see happening in a
very similar way.
And we have a lot of projects in which we are helping implement the FEMAs Chat
Bot,
the femurs.
I'm in customer service and capability,
which is very low risk,
nothing really different.
Critical depends on it.
You can just make someone a bit happier.
You remove friction from the process and moving into using computer vision to
automate a lot of our activities,
but in the interim,
the lower risk tasks,
right?
But we starting to see some traction in places where people are getting more and
more comfortable exploring boarding critical parts of their business in the
hands off of artificial intelligence.
So I guess it's a journey as as as you introduce,
so people just have to get comfortable with
yeah.
Like a pair of shoes,
the artificial intelligence.
So,
so,
so victor mentioned about a computational design of vaccines for example.
So recently you heard that uh,
uh,
I was zero tolerance for any drug vaccine that we take.
I,
um,
requires 100%.
You were asking about a hundred percent.
Why is this,
it's important to us if I have a child and I have to decide whether it's going
to take this vaccine or not.
So that has resulted say in the u s where a lot of people are against the east
vaccinations because the are free,
that he could be leading to all kinds of ailments,
like including autism and so on bag by arguably a fairly tenuous,
uh,
facts.
But if there is a risk that my child may get,
I might say no,
but result is recent outbreak of measles,
for example.
So how do you balance that?
So this is where all these serious ethical considerations and legal issues as
well and where the government has to put in a law that says no,
you know,
for the benefit of the entire community,
we are happy to have 1% of people suffering the negative potential negative
effects.
And that's computes to quite a large number.
If you have a million people,
and it's 1% a cycle of people,
you know,
a heck a lot of children that will be affected by it.
So you've got to weigh that against the,
uh,
public health issues versus the,
the,
um,
uh,
the lack of hundred percent efficacy of anything.
So these are things that,
uh,
I doubt if any AI system can eventually grapple with maybe a I n f a the
ultimate AI ethical system.
Uh,
but that will be another story for another day.
But it's also,
it is critically important for us when we talk about AI in health care,
that we take this into consideration and,
uh,
um,
and,
and really think through the whole process of how we go about introducing a AI
in a measured,
calibrate that and nuanced manner in healthcare.
Oh,
you have an idea for applying AI to healthcare.
Let me know in the comment section and please subscribe for more educational
videos.
For now.
I've got to find a float tank.
So thanks for watching.